let's go next to talking about texas we
talked about in the state of florida
governor ron desantis's approval rating
has collapsed as covid has because
florida rather has become a complete and
total coveted hellscape
deliberately delaying death numbers to
always make it look like deaths are on
the decline just a wacky wacky stuff
going on in florida and the good news is
it's bad that florida is a coveted
hellscape but it's good when a
politician's approval rating responds to
what is going on and it is it is just
and and justified that ron desantis
approval rating has declined greg
abbott's approval rating the governor of
texas has also now hit an all-time low
texas is also having its fair share of
coveted problems article from truthout
outlining this texas governor greg
abbott's approval rating has dropped
over the past month as he has led
republicans in the state to pursue and
pass a number of restrictive and
discriminatory laws over the summer
polling done just before the abortion
ban in the state of texas took effect by
the texas politics project finds that
apple abbott's approval approval rating
went from a net even 44 approval and 44
disapproval in june to a net negative in
the group's most recent poll now 41 of
people polled approve of the gop
governor's job performance while 50
disapprove
abbott's approval rating dropped with
people across the partisan spectrum from
8 to 6 among democrats not a big change
there
77 to 73 among republicans and the
biggest drop 41 down to 30 approval
among independents this is the lowest
approval for greg abbott since he took
office in 2015. the poll found a
majority believe texas is going in the
wrong direction only 35 percent believe
it's going in the right direction
part of the reason for the declining
approval and pessimism may be due to the
pandemic this is really an eye opener
for us the poll found texans generally
disapprove of abbott's handling of the
pandemic that is also at its lowest
level only 39 approval
the delta variant has surged across
texas case rates are now flattening but
the state has some of the highest rates
for infections and deaths and a
relatively low vaccination rate only 48
the mass mandate ban remember some
states
have put in place mass mandates other
states have put in place bans on mass
mandates that's texas that's unpopular
and importantly
the poll was conducted before the
abortion ban went into effect it is
quite plausible
that the abortion ban will also continue
to send greg abbott's approval rating
further and further
into the toilet so this is all
you know my preference would be
that texas better handled covid that
texas didn't ban mass mandates that
texas didn't uh pass oppressive
restrictive abortion bills that would be
my preference but if they are going to
do those things
then
i think it is better for the approval
rating of the governor that's doing it
to to sink and to go into the toilet uh
very often it feels as though
no matter what some of these politicians
do things just remain split among
partisan lines they mostly are remaining
split amongst partisan lines and what i
mean by that is almost no democrats
approve of abbott in texas and the
decline has only been a couple
percentage points
um most republicans approve of abbott
and the decline has been only a couple
percentage points but it's been the
independence where you see that 11
decline
still it is good for the approval
polling to respond to the disastrous
things that greg abbott is doing so
that's texas
let's next talk about georgia
i've struggled falling asleep at night
and realized part of it could be because
of the blue light coming from my phone
and computer screens and peer-reviewed
studies have shown that blue light can
suppress the hormone melatonin which can
make it difficult to fall asleep blue
light can disturb your circadian rhythms
but it hasn't been an issue for me since
i discovered blue blocks glasses which
filter out that blue light they're one
of our sponsors a lot of other companies
are mass producing supposed blue light
glasses and factories with no actual
quality standards blue blocks glasses
are made in actual optics labs at their
headquarters in australia they have over
40 stylish frames a prescription version
non-prescription even reading glasses
and for every pair of glasses that blue
blocks sells they give a pair of reading
glasses to someone in need you'll get 20
off when you go to blue blocks dot com
slash pacman the link is right
underneath this video and there's free
shipping worldwide on orders over a
hundred and fifteen dollars